Well,
we've looked at a number of ways in which the late Elizabeth and,
and early 17th century period was a rather anxious age.
Uh,
and one of the things that the authorities in Elizabethan England and under the
early Stuarts were very generally concerned about was the problem of order,
which naturally raises the question of just how disorderly society was at the
turn of the 16th and 17th centuries.
And today I want to approach that in one way,
uh,
by looking at two of the kinds of crime,
which provided much of the,
um,
serious,
criminal activity dealt with by Elizabeth and devotee steward courts,
uh,
and which will help us to approach this general problem.
Uh,
one aspect of crimes of violence and the other crimes against property and how
they were dealt with.
Okay,
let's start with violence.
So how violent the society was that as a beacon and a re Stuart,
England?
Uh,
it's a question which is quite seriously divided historians,
um,
prior to the 1970s,
I suppose that was a general consensus that it was indeed an exceedingly violent
society by modern standards.
Um,
Lawrence Stone,
the Great Princeton early modernist,
um,
uh,
provides one of the most forthright statements on this point.
He was historian who was good at really forthright statements and in his book
the crisis of the Aristocracy,
he writes that the behavior of the property classes and that of the poor was
characterized by the ferocity childishness and lack of self control of the
Homeric age.
Imagine Brad Pitt in Troy
and unless we can grasp these basic psychological premises,
we cannot hope to understand the scale of the problem which the tutors faced.
That's Lauren Stone.
He continues,
their nerves seem to have been perpetually on edge breeding language in corals,
so intemperate as to be almost deranged and a readiness to resort to direct
action with no holds barred and a general contempt for legal restraint.
Well,
a couple of decades later,
Alan Mcfarlane in a book on crime in the north of England,
the justice and the mayor's Ale took an almost diametrically opposed view.
He quotes contemporary travelers and diarists of the 17th century and concludes
the very strong impression these works give me is of a society in which people
were not moved by irrational anger and fury.
Whether you did not live or travel in fear,
we're despite physical hardship,
there was a great deal of tenderness and affection.
Well,
what I want to suggest in looking at some of the evidence today is that both of
these positions have some merit,
but they're also partial because both are in different ways.
One sided.
And if were to approach this problematic ugly,
we really need to make a number of distinctions,
distinctions geographically between different parts of the kingdom distinctions
socially between the behavior of different groups.
And we need also to look at these matters chronologically with a sense of the
changes which took place over time.
And I've tried to do these things,
but,
uh,
let's begin by looking at some of the special cases,
geographically and socially,
uh,
which will give us a little drama to start with.
There's no doubt,
for example,
that in the late 16th century and into the early decades of the 17th century,
there were some areas of England and Wales which were indeed quite seriously
disorderly and in which violent crime was more or less endemic.
The most notable area of all was the Scottish border area running between
Carlisle and barrack and consisting of high bare hills dividing England from
Scotland,
this whole area and the counties to the south of it where periodically disturbed
by the threat of what was called raving rating conducted by members of the so
called surnames,
members of certain border clans who might be situated on either side of the
border,
also known as Moss troopers,
men who belonged to families like the Armstrongs,
the grahams,
the Wrigley's,
the Robson's,
the halls,
the fosters,
the Elliot's,
the Dixons.
I noticed looking through the roster,
we have a Dixon in this class which is quite worrying.
These were people who would set up when the,
when the opportunity provided itself on their little Galloway ponies generally
armed with a leather jacket,
jerkin and a steel cap dagger at the back of on the saddle.
Lance and sword to raid and they rated both the other side of the border and in
their own kingdoms also.
Um,
it was set of the Armstrongs and the Grahams was a contemporary proverb,
Armstrong's and Graham's ride thieves all,
well,
these were the Mohs troopers,
the border rivers.
Um,
I've actually looked at the indictments for the courts for the county of
Northumberland between Newcastle and Barak.
And they reveal a great deal of the activities of these people.
Um,
they're quite distinctive compared to other criminal records.
Instead of finding someone accused,
for example of,
of stealing a hand or a piglet or something like that,
kind of commonplace thefts in this area,
you find people accused of stealing 20 cattle or 40 sheep of attacking houses,
of taking people for ransom.
Um,
so many of those involved belonged to these particular surnames,
particular families who were notorious,
um,
that they were frequently given nicknames because so many of them had the same
name and these survival.
So in the wreck chords.
Um,
so for example,
amongst the men who were accused in Northumberland in the 1580s and nineties of
receiving or of slaying use with using swords,
daggers or lances,
we find,
for example,
a Thomas Armstrong known as George.
He's Tom,
his father was called George.
So he's Jody's Tom.
We have William Wrigley known as SLAC.
We'll,
we've got William Hall known as Saucy will.
We have John Dodd's alias,
crooked Jock,
uh,
John Foster,
alias,
read,
John and so on.
Could go on.
I think you'd get the general idea.
Um,
my favorite border,
he was in fact a Scotsman,
Clement Crosier,
who was known by the wonderful nickname of Nablus,
Clem nebulous Clem and nab in the dialect of the area is the tip of your nose.
That's your Neb and nebulous.
Clem had lost the tip of his nose in a sword fight.
Broadswords stroke.
It taken off the end of his nose.
So he was known ever after is nebulous Clem.
And so one could go on.
So in 1,603 when Elizabeth the first died,
the Graham family on the border decided that until King James,
the sixth of Scotland reached the south of England and was crowned as James the
first of England.
The laws were temporarily suspended and they set off to take advantage of that
fact.
In a week they rated south as far south as a Penrith in Cumbria and it became
known as busy week.
They took 5,000 cattle.
They did almost 7,000 pounds worth of damage to property.
They captured 14 men whom they held for ransom.
And in the course of attempts to resist them,
they killed another six.
So this is the kind of thing which could happen though.
It's an extreme example.
Now,
none of this of course is typical,
but it existed.
It was going on on the border in the border counties,
and it needs to be considered.
And in fact,
the Welsh border,
they'll less bad was also an area which was known for its relative lawlessness
because of the possibility of criminal slipping between jurisdictions across the
border.
Right?
So if the geographical periphery of the kingdom had some rather special
problems,
then so too did the social periphery of the aristocracy and the Gentry,
uh,
Lawrence Stone in the crisis of the aristocracy sites,
far too many specific cases of aristocratic and gentry violence to be ignored.
These were people who could be exceedingly touchy about personal honor and
willing sometimes to resort to extreme measures to revenge slights against their
honor.
Um,
some of them indeed were virtually above the law in their capacity to get away
with it.
Um,
so for example,
it's a fact that in 1589,
so Thomas Langton and 80 of his men besieged the Thomas Hotan and 30 of his men
in Lee Hall in Lancashire up in the northwest.
And when they broke in,
they killed Houghton and several of his defenders,
when the government established a special commission to look into this
particularly bad example of feuding amongst the Gentry,
only three of the jurors who were appointed dead to turn up the rest were too
intimidated by the local power of those responsible.
And in fact,
no formal present moment of this offense was ever made.
At Law,
the Privy Council had to deal with it in other ways or to take another example
in 1580 the Earl of Oxford,
the man whom some people think wrote Shakespeare's plays,
but got an illegitimate child on a gentle woman who was under the protection of
Sir Thomas Navid.
And that resulted in a feud between the two,
which included an assassination attempt on divot in London and several armed a
phrase between their retainers and servants in the streets of London in which
four men were killed and three were seriously wounded.
And yet the courtiers responsible with too powerful to be actually indicted in
the courts.
Again,
the Privy Council pacified it in other ways.
Well,
that kind of aristocratic and gentry violence could be added to from all over
the kingdom.
It was the results of a code of behavior,
which later stress on competitive assertiveness in defense of a man's face and
pride and reputation and one which could assume in some cases at any rate that
resort to violence was both natural and justifiable.
Well,
the special problems that are posed by both the geographical and the social
peripheries.
We're fully recognized by contemporary authorities and the tutor and early
steward state did it's best to try to deal with them.
The northern and Welsh boarders where under the special jurisdiction of
particular councils established after 1560 to deal with their special problems.
The council of the north sitting in York,
the council in the marches of whales sitting in Ludlow and they labored to bring
offenders to heal wardens of the marches were appointed who also also had the
duty of cooperating with their opposite numbers on the other side of the border
in order to bring offenders to heal.
Some of them did some successfully,
some not so successfully in Northumberland.
So John Foster,
who was the warden of this part of the border,
um,
was notoriously in league with most of the border,
even families himself.
Uh,
but he was succeeded by others who did the job better.
one of them,
Robert Carey loved it.
You wrote with enthusiasm to one of his friends in the south.
Have you spent every day in the saddle pursuing people across the border.
Um,
when Elizabeth died,
he was selected to be the man to carry her ring to Scotland to give to James a
six as a token of his succession.
They chose him because a,
he was a good writer and B,
they thought he could get through the border safely.
Board of commissioners were appointed by James the sixth and first when he
became king of England in order to cooperate even more closely.
And indeed the level of violence and the board of county steadily diminishes
from that point onwards.
By the 1620s,
it was largely over by the 1640s in some local histories.
It was being recalled as a rather romantic past rather than,
uh,
rather terrifying present reality
again,
in dealing with feuds and corals amongst the aristocracy and Gentry,
the Privy Council did its best to try to pacify and restrain people.
It heard complaints,
alternative channels through which feuds could be settled.
It made inquiries,
it's summon defenders before it to answer it forced arbitration upon upon people
whose feuds might lead to violence.
It put them under bond to keep the peace.
The Court of Star Chamber sitting in Westminster was particularly active in
dealing with riotous and violent behavior amongst lesser offenders going out
fines and imprisonment and so forth,
and they use of crown patronage could also help to keep people in line if they
wanted to retain royal favor.
Gradual success in measures of this kind can be traced.
That kind of behavior became less common as a 17th century advanced and it was
probably a company buy something of a shifted social values.
Humanist educators of the period were beginning to teach an alternative notion
of honor and nobility which laid greater stress upon civility and restraint and
service to the state rather than on a prickly form of individual honor.
That was the influence of Protestant preachers to who preached her sober and
restrained model of manhood.
All this was slow to affect behavior,
but perhaps significant in the long run in changing the expectations of what was
tolerable behavior amongst the elite.
Indeed,
it could be said in some ways that they were providing a model of sort of,
sort of new man for the period.
There were limits to the success of all that competitive assertion was still
commonplace.
Uh,
even in such a peaceful environment as the University of Cambridge in the late
16th century,
outbreaks of violence amongst the students were actually quite common.
There are many records of students.
Disciplined for such activities is pulling one another's beards,
which was a way to insult someone if you're in a quarrel with them,
pull their beard.
It was thought to be terribly humiliating.
Um,
or,
um,
activities such as in a 60,
no one,
I think it was when the students of St John's College,
uh,
attacked Trinity College on mass armed with clubs.
Um,
they were repelled by the students of Trinity College who climbed to the top of
the tower and through pieces of masonry down on the attacking mob.
Um,
this had to be quelled by the university watch and many of the students concern
were whipped in their college halls or put in the stocks in their college halls
as a means of discipline.
Uh,
and so on could go on the records of University of chemistry.
Extremely interesting in this respect and one occasion in the 60 90 is a group
of students pretended to be the city watch and went around forcing taverns which
had closed for the night to open and serve them.
They trashed the cross keys tavern and again there was a major disciplinary
action as a result of this.
One of those who trashed the cross keys tavern was a future bishop of Durham
because he was there training for the clergy.
One could go on the dual also remained of course a feature of aster cratic
culture for a long time.
They're examples of dueling right through to the 19th century.
Most prime ministers of Britain fought a duel at one time or another right up to
the Duke of Wellington in the early 19th century.
But that was the kind of individual one on one violence,
not as common as it's sometimes thought and very different from open feuding
with gangs of armed retainers,
which had been the kind of thing which had existed earlier.
But to move on,
what about the,
the heart of the kingdom and less elevated offenders and that can be approached
by looking at the records for homicide.
The records of your size courts at the king's bench,
which met in London,
a contained many inquests and indictments for homicide.
Uh,
they're pretty full and these provide a fair opportunity to examine the actual
incidents of crimes of this kind.
It was a hard crime to conceal when someone was killed and investigation by
coroner's was virtually automatic,
which could lead to criminal prosecution.
Jia Sharp in his book,
crime in early modern England has attempted for part of the mid 17th century to
produce an actual rate of homicide crimes per 100,000 population.
And he calculates that the homicide rate in mid 17th century England was about
three times that of modern Britain.
It may indeed have been somewhat higher since sometimes coroner's inquests would
fail to bring a charge in circumstances where today it would almost certainly be
listed as a homicide.
Others have also attempted calculations of this kind and what they tend to bring
out.
They all agree the figures vary,
but they all agree that the levels of indictment for homicide,
we're actually gradually falling from the late 16th century right through to the
late 18th century in fact,
and some of the figures that have been produced or they're on one of the tables
on your handout.
If you look at table two
it's worth looking at in detail,
but if you just look at the last two columns there you have the a rate
calculated per hundred thousand population for the counties of Surrey and Sussex
Urban,
sorry,
is London,
south London.
Then we have rural,
sorry.
Then it total for the whole county and we also have the figures for Sussex,
sorry,
is here to the south of London.
Sussex is on the south coast and what you'll see you,
there is a steady decline in the rate of homicide gradual process of
pacification.
One could say,
okay,
so this suggests perhaps that it was indeed a period with more serious violence
than our own,
but not one which was in new or to simply casual slaughter.
We seem to be somewhere in between Laurence stones violence and unrestrained
emotional infants and Alan Mcfarland's.
Nice orderly Englishman.
Okay.
The circumstances of the cases that were heard,
um,
bring that out even more.
Um,
in the 16th and 17th centuries,
people killed their families less and their neighbors more than is the case
today in 17th Century Essex and indeed in late 16th Century Essex to,
um,
violent slaying was much less confined to the family and modern Britain.
About 50% of homicides take place within the family.
In Essex,
in the early modern period,
it was only 21%,
even if you include the killing of servants.
So violence is more broadly spread in society,
but the killing was rarely premeditated.
It usually a rose from quite spontaneous resort to violence in the course of a
quarrel.
In many ways,
the homicide cases that survive in the wreck chords,
we're actually cases of aggravated assault.
Jia sharp has analyzed the weapons that were used.
He finds a poisoning,
very calculated act of homicide was very rare.
Guns and swords and knives were rarely used,
which is perhaps surprising since nearly everyone carried a knife to cut up
their foot.
Even housewives,
jeopardy carry two knives.
There's a batch of their position in the family.
They had double sheets with two knives to use about their duties.
The commonest weapons used for homicide in this period where simply tools,
which people have picked up in a moment of anger or sticks or cudgels,
oss,
fists and feet.
More than two thirds of the cases examined by sharp people,
killed others with their fists or their feet.
These were brawls then which resulted in a death.
Okay,
so homicide emerges is largely a question of violence arising amongst neighbors
in the course of day to day quarrels.
It does indeed suggest that there was a degree of willingness to strike out with
relatively small provocation,
which is unfamiliar,
at least among men.
Women are very rarely involved.
They turn up in homicide cases,
usually only under very special circumstances of accusations,
of witchcraft or of infanticide.
So
before coming to the conclusion that this was a significantly more violence
society than our own,
we should also take into account the fact that in the 17th and 20th centuries,
the figures are not strictly comparable.
Many of those who died as a result of such casual violence in the 17th century,
you would actually have been saved today by modern medical techniques.
The crimes concerned would be down a serious assault rather than as homicide and
what has to allow for that.
But nevertheless,
something was going on in the period,
a gradual decline in the rates of homicide.
Even though modern medical techniques had not come in during the period of the
covered by the tables that you have there.
So something is going on
overall.
Then one can say some areas of the kingdom which should provide a special
problems were being pacified.
Some social groups who presented a special problem.
We're being pacified and it seems likely that the higher degree of spontaneous
violence amongst otherwise respectable people was gradually being reduced.
There were limits to the violence of the period limits to what was regarded as
tolerable.
Serious efforts to try to contain it and the figures suggest that they were
meeting some success.
Okay,
well let's turn now to crimes against property.
If violence might seem to us,
the principal indicator of the orderliness of a society.
Contemporaries were actually much more concerned with the problem of trends in
theft.
Many of them believed that they were witnessing and at the turn of the 16th and
17th centuries something of a wave of crimes against property.
And when you look at the records,
it's always property crimes which predominate in the evidence that survives.
If you look at your handout table one that breaks down the crimes dealt with by
various court jurisdiction in the counties I've marked on the map here.
And overwhelmingly property offenses dominate those statistics.
Property crimes of all sorts in fact seem to have been rising in most of the
areas of England for which we have evidence from roughly the 1580s through to
roughly the 1620s and then gradually diminishing.
And there's an example of that in table three on your handout where we have the
figures for Chester in the northwest,
which has very good records.
And you get that upward trend followed by a significantly lower level of
property offenses later in the 17th century.
Well certain trends can be discerned then a real problem at the turn of the
century getting somewhat better later on,
but when we talk about property crime of course it's a rather than blanket term
and it covers a multitude of specific offenses.
There are two principle distinctions in property crime that we need to take note
of.
First of all,
they made a distinction between capital and non capital.
Forms of theft,
capital forms of theft with were those which were punished by death and they
included highway robbery,
burglary and housebreaking and also thefts of goods worth more than one
shilling.
It's about a day's wage for a London Labor,
12 pence,
one shilling.
If you stole goods worth more than 12 pencil,
one shilling,
you were guilty of grand larceny and that carried the death penalty.
Then there were non capital thefts,
Petty Larceny,
goods of lesser value valued at less than one shilling that was punishable by
whipping,
so they distinguished capital and non capital.
Secondly,
they distinguished forms of property offense,
which were clergy payable and those which were non clergy table.
What did that mean?
A clergy or bill offense was one which was subject to benefit of clergy,
benefit of clergy.
That meant
that a person found guilty even of a capital crime,
could escape hanging by claiming benefit of clergy by claiming to be a member of
the clergy.
It was a hangover from the medieval laws,
which had exempted the clergy from the jurisdiction of the state's courts by
this period.
It was a complete fiction,
but they continued to use it in the procedures of the courts.
You proved that you deserve to benefit of clergy by proving that you could read
and you proved that you could read by reading what was known as the neck verse
because it saved your neck.
The neck verse Psalm 51 verse one it's very appropriate.
Have mercy upon me.
Oh Lord.
According to thy loving kindness,
according to the multitude of thy tender mercies,
blot out my transgression.
If you could read that successfully,
you would be spared.
Grand Larceny was clergy table.
Though some offenses were considered so serious that clergy was not permitted.
Housebreaking burglary,
highway robbery,
and some other offenses,
clergy applied only to men because only men could be members of the clergy,
but a woman found guilty of a capital offense was allowed to plead her belly as
they put it.
That's to say she could claim that she believed herself to be pregnant.
If so,
she would be spared.
Since it was clearly unjust to hang a pregnant woman and if so spared,
she might ultimately be reprieved after the birth of the child.
So much for definitions.
Then the problem in discussing property crime is that though one can understand
the system of how they dealt with it well enough,
it's impossible to establish the actual incidents of these crimes because what
we have in the court records are not the records of all crimes committed,
but simply the records of those that got prosecuted and that leaves us with what
people refer to as the dark number of offenses that we just don't know about.
In 1596 for example,
one justice of the peace for Somerset said that in his opinion,
only about a fifth of the property offenses which were committed ever came
before the courts.
The rest went on prosecuted largely because people didn't consider it worth the
time and trouble and charge of bringing a case over over goods,
which were of low value.
Nevertheless,
as the figures show,
there was a considerable rise in the numbers of people who were prosecuted at
the turn of the 16th and 17th centuries
that might possibly be accounted for partly by population rise,
but also there appears to have been a real increase over and above what can be
accounted for by simply a rising population.
So then are we dealing with a real increase in property crime,
a crime wave under Elizabeth and the early Stuart's,
or on the other hand,
is it just a tightening up of the law,
not an increase in crime,
but an increase in prosecution?
Well,
I'd suggest that it was a bit of both
in considering the problem.
It's,
it's helpful to ask the simple questions,
you know,
who were the thieves,
what were the circumstances of their offenses and so forth.
There's very little evidence in the court record hoards of the existence of a
professional criminal class in England.
It certainly existed in London.
London is another special case in London.
Certainly had a core of professional criminals,
but elsewhere,
it's rare to find people repeatedly prosecuted in the courts from whom for whom
one can reconstruct a criminal career.
They exist and their careers.
We're not necessarily cut off by being hanged for their first defense as we'll
see,
but they seem to have been few of them.
The nearest thing you get to a criminal class in the countryside were vagrants
who might steal as part of the way in which they manage to get by.
And occasionally delinquent families in particular villages who seem to have
been held responsible for a lot of petty offenses.
Uh,
in one village I worked on in Lancashire,
for example,
there was a man who was known locally by the nickname desperate Tom.
Uh,
because of the frequency with which he was involved in petty crime.
Of one kind or another.
There were such people but not a professional criminal class in the sense that
we might expect it.
Most defenders turn out to have been drawn from the lowest ranks of the rural
population.
Laborers,
poor craftsman servants.
These are the people who are disproportionately represented.
You very rarely find yeoman farmers or husband,
man or craftsmen of substance being press presented.
They're overwhelmingly men.
You very rarely find women being prosecuted.
Only about 15% of those accused of property crimes in the county of Hartford
Cheer,
for example,
to the north of London were women and other counties have similar figures.
Most of the offenses they committed also turn out to have been rather
opportunistic acts.
What you get is someone stealing perhaps a small animal,
which it's strayed or taking small goods,
which they happened to have the opportunity to pilfer and most students of the
problem suggest that for many of the rural,
poor,
occasional petty pilfering of that kind may have been part and parcel of the way
they got by.
That certainly brought out vividly in years of bad harvest or trade depression
in the town of Manchester.
For example,
in the fairly normal years,
1615 to 1621 there were about 13 people tried for property offenses each year in
the bad harvest year of 1622 to 1623 the finger shot up to 38 and that kind of
fluctuation in particular crisis years is something that has been found in every
county that's been studied.
Sometimes you have the detailed circumstances of cases in the examinations or
the confessions of those who were brought to trial and that provides supporting
evidence.
For example,
in 1626 in your county of Worcestershire,
a man called William Bride was prosecuted for stealing a sheep and he said he
confessed and said in his own defense that the same ship was rotten.
That's to say it was sick and that he took it for one to food to relieve his
wife or again,
in 1623 Robert Whitehead,
a laborer from the village of Tiling and Essex stole and with his family,
ate a sheep and he confessed and said that he did it having a wife and seven
small children and being hungry.
They actually identified him as the teeth because they found a skin of the sheep
in his cottage.
It had been eaten.
These things considered,
it may very well appear that the general rise in the incidence of theft in the
court records at the turn of the 16th and 17th centuries,
especially these petty thefts may relate to the general process of polarization
of the rural poor,
which we've already observed being at its worst in this period and as an
excellent study of this,
which you find on the reading list by Peter Lawson called property crime and
hard times.
However,
of course that's only part of the explanation.
One can't simply equate poverty and theft.
Clearly most of the poor didn't steal and of those who did not all were
prosecuted and various other considerations are at work in the kinds of figures
that we have from the court records.
Often cases weren't brought because victims of crime simply couldn't be bothered
with the expense and trouble involved having to bring a case of themselves,
especially if the goods had been recovered,
which they sometimes where when goods were found missing those off to search by
the constable.
If they were recovered,
the victim quite frequently declined to prosecute.
That was sometimes partly out of pity for the thief,
not least because the person responsible and might very often be a neighbor,
someone well known to them.
There was definitely a preference for mediation in settling disputes of all
kinds at the local level.
The early 17th century clergyman,
George Herbert clergymen and poet wrote and advised that in such cases,
gentle and neighborly admonition was the best course to take.
One should prosecute in the courts only if a delinquent persisted in delinquent
activity.
So what it is you
in understanding how these cases came up to be recorded in the court records is
of course the whole tenor of social relationships within particular
neighborhoods.
And it's not surprising that people have found when they looked very closely at
cases heard in the courts that those who were prosecuted as Steve's very often
have particular characteristics.
They were often outsiders,
not members of the village community,
not sheltered by being known,
perhaps even liked within the village.
They will often,
if they weren't outside as very marginal people,
the kind of people who were accused of witchcraft,
for example,
they were sometimes known delinquents who had finally exhausted the patients of
the local community by persisting in their activities.
But even when they were actually brought before the courts,
there were various ways in which the full rigor of the law could be spared.
Sometimes having brought a prosecution in order to scare someone,
the victim would allow it to lapse by not turning up to see the case through the
grand jury's,
which had to look at the cases in the courts,
vetter d indictments,
which were brought before them very carefully and they could be very
conscientious in weeding out cases in which they considered the evidence to be
deficient or they suspected that there might be an element of malice.
In the prosecution or were they simply decided that in the circumstances of the
case they were going to be merciful.
They vetted each case if they wanted it to go to trial.
They endorsed the indictment,
biller Vera,
a true bill,
and it went forward if they thought it could be,
it should lapse.
They endorsed the bill ignoramus.
They wrote the word ignoramus on the bill.
Literally,
we do not know and the case would be dropped
in the county of Sussex in the early 17th century,
as many as a quarter of indictments were actually dropped in this way by the
grand jury or again,
if the case came to trial trial,
juries of neighbors frequently failed to convict.
Some of them were moved probably by a degree of compassion for the person before
them.
They frequently indulged in the practice of reducing the valuation of the goods
which had been stolen so that a person would get a lesser conviction.
So for example,
they may might have someone before them for stealing a sheep valued at two
shillings,
which would have carried the death penalty.
They decided that the person needs punishing but not that severely and so they
would find them guilty,
but reduces the value of the sheep to 10 or 11 pounds,
which would mean petty larceny and the person concerned would be whipped rather
than hand.
All of that was extremely common.
For example,
in Elizabeth and Essex of fifth of all property offenses had the valuation
reduced in that manner.
I'd finally,
there was use of benefit of clergy.
This was very important indeed in Elizabeth and Essex,
only a tiny proportion of those who were convicted of stealing sheep,
which was clergy bubble.
We're actually sentenced to hang.
It could be as low as 6% in particular years.
The rest were permitted clergy,
and since the levels of literacy were so low in this period that it seems highly
unlikely that such a high proportion of of,
of,
of felons could actually read.
It's perfectly clear that the magistrates and the judges were permitting any
kind of stumbling through the next verse,
often from memory,
probably in order to allow them to have this means of escaping the death penalty
of that,
to give you the precise figures of 790 people who were allowed to attempt to
read in the courts of Elizabeth and Essex,
only nine failed to do so
and finally convicted and condemned felons were not infrequently reprieved.
If the judge thought that there was a case for mercy,
the judge ended every asides caught by recommending those who would be
reprieved,
especially if there were respectable members of the community who are willing to
speak for them.
All of this goes to show quite clearly that the apparent savagery of the law did
not in practice vent itself on people quite as severely as one might suspect or
certainly not in an unrestrained manner.
It was used with a great deal of discretion and discretion in the way the law
was used as something of a keyword for historians of criminal justice in this
period.
That issue discretion and how it was used is absolutely central to the two
classic articles which you'll be reading for next week's section in one of them.
Douglas Haye has argued that this use of discretion was a quite calculated
policy by the magistrates to balance the terror of the law with the practice of
mercy.
And by doing so to retain the gratitude and the deference of the poor.
Make examples of a few pardon the rest.
It's conducive to order.
That's his argument.
Cynthia Harrop takes a rather different line.
She argues that the operation of the law involved many elements of participation
by rulers and rules,
uh,
like not only the judges and the magistrates,
but the members of jewelries and so forth.
As many as three dozen people could be involved in a case from its earliest
investigation through to the actual trial.
And she suggested amongst such people there were certain shared ideals of
justice,
which meant that they tended to practice the gradual shifting out at various
stages of the case of those whom they deemed to be truly culpable,
truly criminal.
Those hanged with those who stole for profit,
who stole in a planned manner,
who were strangers who failed to confess and express remorse.
And she argues that this expressed what was fundamentally a religious attitude
that all people are potentially sinful but only some are so hardened in evil
that they are incapable of reformation.
Well these are cases you can read for yourself and debate next week.
So then discretion was widely used,
but nevertheless it should also be emphasized that non of this leniency and
clemency and discretion could be guaranteed.
The terror of the law was often mitigated by justice and by mercy,
but that was at the discretion of prosecutors have neighbors of jury,
men and judges.
And it wasn't always forthcoming.
There was no ultimate guarantee that only the most guilty would be sentenced to
a flogging or the hangman's noose.
And there's also evidence that in those difficult generations in the last years
of Elizabeth and the early years of the Stuart's,
something of a greater punitive harshness was being used in the courts.
The harshness greater than that.
That was later to be the case.
I mean more prosecutions,
less use of benefit of clergy and indeed more executions.
In the final six years of Elizabeth's reign at the county town of Chelmsford in
Essex,
they were hanging 28 26 people a year in public
in the 1620s 17 a year were being hanged at Chester between 1,616 10 25 a year
were being hanged at Exeter down in the South West.
It's been estimated that perhaps 600 plus people were publicly hanged every year
in the last years of Elizabeth and the early years of King James.
The first,
and those are pretty high figures by the standards of what we know about later
periods,
especially the 18th and 19th centuries when most counties saw only a handful of
executions in each year.
To give you a comparison,
which might be more meaningful.
I read yesterday in the Times that in Texas there have been 334 executions since
1997 which works out at an average of almost 26 a year.
The same figure as were being hanged in Chelmsford Essex in 50 97 but Essex had
a population of approximately a hundred thousand Texas has a population of 26
million,
so in other words,
the rate per million in Texas of executions annually is just over one one per
million.
The rate in late Elizabethan England was 150 per million.
The point I'm making,
obviously as it,
despite the many mitigating circumstances which were used in done,
still had a pretty bloody criminal code and it was still pretty bloody Lee
enforced on hardened evil doers certainly,
but also perhaps sometimes on those who simply didn't have the position or the
connections who were outsiders who were vagrants and could not escape the rigor
of the law through the use of discretion.
We mustn't exaggerate the ferocity of the law,
but equally we mustn't forget.
It's very harsh realities in this period.
At its very heart,
we're not only certain social ideals of justice regarding who most deserved such
a punishment,
but also what's been described as the logic of exemplary punishment.
They believed that since they could not deal with all crime,
they must make examples of some,
and they did on a scale,
which by modern standards is shocking.
Okay.
We can leave it
next time.
I've gone to look at another aspect of order,
the
small scale forms of popular protest,
demonstrations and riots,
which one finds in this period.